entre laury thilleman est le chef roy
darbellay c'est fini c'était pas mon
style mais j'étais pas le sien non plus
à travers un message sur ces réseaux
sociaux que la miss france a annoncé
leur rupture hier afin de couper court à
toutes rumeurs et articles nauséabond je
souhaitais vous partagez qu'après sept
ans de bonheur intense et d'une vie à
mille à l'heure roanne et moi décidons
ensemble de continuer nos routes
séparément une nouvelle qui a surpris
les fans alors que le couple s'était
marié il ya à peine trois ans on s'est
rendu compte très vite qu'on a beaucoup
de choses en commun de son côté roanne
harvey l'aise a diffusé un message
similaire sur son compte en précisant
qu'il avait décidé de se quitter en bons
termes laurie sera pour moi un exemple
de joie force détermination et je
garderai en tête que des souvenirs
lumineux aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
couples annoncent leur séparation avant
que la presse ne le fassent à leur place
alors laury thilleman est le chef
roinard baileys annoncent la fin de leur
couple faut-il médiatiser les ruptures
[Musique]
florian merci d'être là bonjour
alors ma mère allait remonter contre
elisabeth et idéalement mais c'est vrai
ça tu lui diras tu es des cours
d'histoire lundi
l'aquila
étudiera et l'ivi que c'était pendant le
protectorat et que c'était la franche
bastien a oui et pas bloquer numéro de
ta mère
alors là défaut de paiement il n'y aura
pas l'année prochaine
déjà commencé à installer sport très
énervé contre elisabeth lévy et à les
remonter à mon avis je peux dire va lui
mettre une chèque choquait dans la
tronche et un
merci florian d'être là merci alors sa
revanche et je sais que la hauteur
fréquentent les meilleurs on essaye
merci bien faire l'honneur d'être avec
nous alors vous avez vu laury thilleman
a annoncé sa rupture avec son mari afin
de couper court à toutes les rumeurs et
artistes nauséabond je souhaitais vous
partagez qu'après sept ans de bonheur
intense et d'une vie commune à mille à
l'heure 3d moi décidons ensemble de
continuer notre route séparément à dire
que
la tendresse la tendresse quand on peut
se dire que j'étais à
la tendresse la bienveillance
la gratitude et de respect mutuel que
nous partageons reste il restera intacte
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est ça
le sens nous vous prions de bien vouloir
respecter notre silence après cette
annonce et si ça marche roanne a égayé
ma vie de mille couleurs et je suis anti
et aura toujours une place à part dans
mon coeur
merci pour ce chemin parcouru
merci pour la joie
l'amour les rires
et chaque apprenti c'est très joli
vive la france
vive le charles-de-gaulle lille
bernadette et vive la république bravo
donc laurie-anne on s'est alors dit ce
que vous pensez de ce qu'elle appelle
laurier moi je pense que ce contient pas
mal parce que moi l1 laurent p
l'appareil elle couper l'herbe sous le
pied comme on lit dans le milieu du
jardinage ouais mais en fait c'est
l'herbe ce l'herbe de quel pied en fait
parce qu'elle parle alors déjà - ya deux
choses elle parle d'articles nauséabond
mais déjà déjà près de 2 kg et parle pas
de logique ou de noms mais je sais pas
bah voila moi je vous dis de qui elle
parle parce que article nauséabond c'est
à dire qu'elles ciblent la presse people
peut être un petit peu la presse télé se
font en fait on s'en fout dire que nous
on a fait une brève sur sa rupture chez
closer et ça mérite pas plus on n'a rien
contre elle non en fait ça vous en prie
bouger une fois un petit peu quoi c'est
à dire que bref parce que elle a fait le
communiqué où vous auriez vous
c'est à dire que c'est pas un personnage
enfin là je parle pour moi j'aime bien
les socialistes people je n'ai rejet
pour moi c'est pas un personnage parce
que c'était mon jeune âge clé un
personnage important quoi ça en fait
vous êtes en train de dire on s'en bat
les couilles exactement
avec douceur voilà c'est à dire mais
c'est vous faites ça vous dit non mais
vous dit en fait que vous êtes en train
de dire en plus moi j'aime bien le oui
mais en fait ils vous diraient sans rien
dire on n'aurait pas fait la une de
succursales vrai du tout même en plus je
la marge de la rencontre il suggère fois
c'est super sympa j'attends une bonne
animatrice
à s'être il y en a il y en a
quelques-unes belle c'est vraiment bien
reconverti c'est une très très bonne
animation et je trouve que c'est dommage
le message qu'elle pose parce qu'elle
essaye de faire passer la presse people
en dix ans le pur des ports pour des bas
pour des personnages nauséabond terme
qu'il en viendra sauf que franchement si
on avait eu l'info je ne sais même pas
s'ils ont leur est sorti déjà parce que
son mec on le connaît pas bien c'est pas
quelqu'un de 2,7 fois nar malaise ouais
bon voilà c'est moyen voilà avec
quelqu'un d'autre a brillé passera le
relais qu'attiser le a peut-être que je
m'appuierai sur tech matthieu delormeau
voilà ça c'est un scoop de foule
et on y va méchamment à
mathieu et dans les séries on aimerait
qu'ils préfèrent l'abricot
bel et bien un jour c'est ça mais
attendez je vous dis c'est pas parce
qu'on a mangé des bananes toute sa vie
qu'on mange pas put abricots que vous
parlez
oui gilles verlant mais florian n'oublie
pas complètement coire et parce qu'il
est amer à coeur d'être toujours non
mais j'aime beaucoup mais là c'est la
grande idée oui moi aussi c'est
fantastique
non mais non mais non moi ce que j'aime
pas c'est que si vous aviez eu des
pourquoi il sait pas peut-être que
lindon d2 a envie de refaire sa vie ou
refait sa vie et ses roues ce soir si
vous aviez les photos les photos vous
les auriez publié des photos des photos
ne jamais donner de l argent sa vie avec
quelqu'un dont il met donc qui coupe
court à s'arrêter c'est ça qui vous
déplaît assuré klein pour échapper à la
presse people et ça vous le soir vous
êtes en train de penser que l'un des
deux trains de paille jeudi c'est
possible et si c'est ça ils vont guetter
les photos qui vont valoir cher surtout
si c est la défense adaptés de nos
pipeauté mon cher
la route et la flore
mais que même si l'un des deux se
remettaient avec quelqu'un en bas les
coups ça n'a aucun intérêt
permet effectivement avec quelqu'un
c'est pas d' extrêmement connue assez
fascinant pardon de le dire mais je
n'avais pas là mais elles ces personnes
ça n'intéresse pas du tout même s'en
fout florian bah oui j'en avais créé mon
club avec raymond raymond c'est un
personnage aujourd'hui c'est vraiment il
est tous les soirs dans tpm pc en fait
loris mais avec raymond on y va voilà
alors je pense qu'on n'a pas
lounge il a raison c'est que d'être un
peu hypocrite que si laury se remet avec
quelqu'un peu importe la personne vous
allez quand même en faire quelque chose
ça sera quand même qu'avec tandis que ça
dépend de la personne valérie blais les
plans d'un côté vous arriver ça dépend
de la personne et quel que soit le genre
c'est quelqu'un d'inconnu on s'en fout
pardon ça risque vraiment celle avec mig
wallonie dans vos magazines quand même
mais bien sûr mais on parle d'elle mais
attendez de moi je l'aï interviewé sur
son hygiène de vie je suis un photo
d'elle mais oui beauté mode et tout donc
elle est quand même elle est présente
quand même n'est exactement simplement
je m'accroche la première qui a fait ce
genre de déclarations quand ils se sont
séparés c'est gwyneth paltrow avec chris
martin elle avait fait
le plein
d'autres aides en séries si martin
nuls 1 kamel est sur un créneau beauté
voyez pas trop a lancé un empire à
partir de là parce qu'elle avait même
fait un concept qui était le camp
tchèque a pointé la séparation conscient
qu'aux
messages me fait penser au message de
la bataille de tomates révolutionner sur
ce créneau là aller mais le prénom le
problème c'est qu elle le choisit
elle-même sans se demander si elle est
un personnage people qui intéresse les
gens c'est à dire moi c'est ça que
j'essaie d'exprimer depuis tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'un horrible
qu'il marque yoplait on s'intéresse à ça
c'est les connaissons s'intéresse à
cette chasse qui reste qu'on a envie de
voir les mecs cools chercher de quoi
c'est qu'il ya même map et externe of
sadness très fort mais par exemple en
fait c'est pas nous qui avons envie de
les voir c'est les gens qui achètent un
corner qu'est-ce qui est
engagée à marion cotillard il ya
jennyfer il ya évidemment qu'il y avait
là-bas c'est la poularde star du foot
français aujourd'hui donc il suffit de
regarder le lire un peu la presse people
et vous verrez qu'il ya une dizaine de
personnages dans la pac 40 il y en a une
dizaine sakouli laury thilleman est ce
plat elle pose sur positionne
d'elle-même taille remstar en fait trois
dames et raymond c'est sérieux elle se
positionne elle même comme une star
genre on va se jeter sur son couple mais
je n'ai même pas dans votre magazine il
n'y a pas que des grandes stars et elle
elle énormément suivi quand même parle
sur les réseaux sociaux ils ont médias
donc mieux connaître sans victoire
rennes on met d'accord mais
toi mais sans
les modes et travaux il
convenait alors rires moi d'abord ce
ballet puis avec les puits avec lui on
sait c'est malheureux je pense que c'est
elle qui l'a même pas ce que je fais une
synthèse vous êtes certaine non il est
adorable
elle a bien parlé remet ce que ça vaut
de l'oseille delormeau ça vaut de
l'oseille non sans rigoler que dalle tu
le nom united et non pas de menaces à
vous un cerveau pas de l'anim jamais de
la vie le dossard konan qui parle avec
de leurs maux non non pas moi les
samoans a lui la vie privée de la vie
privée des ponts avec qui s'est toujours
senti que de 10 ans vaut si je suis avec
quelqu'un voilà qui
est oui non mais tomber quelqu'un dans
sa défense ça dépend de la personne avec
is a way bah oui c'est ça c'est pas de
leur mot tout seul ou ses terrils tous
l1 plus
intense à 10
du coup tu as plus de taf voilà
pour sa dernière fois que j'ai fait une
une le garçon fait qu'ils essayent ils
avaient pris dix mille cas ce que lui
inconnu un mois j'ai pris trois mais
cinq ans parce que on savait que je suis
gay parce que nadja rien pris en plus
j'ai payé son avocat
il t'a laissé tomber c'est ça
il est venu chez moi après je réside à
pour finir et 20 juste moi j'aurais pu
faire ça quand je me suis séparé de
flavie honnêtement si regretté travail
j'ai été traqué c'est la folie furieuse
de la une de tous les magazines pendant
quatre ans c'est normal des semaines je
voyais avec i à iv c'était un enfer
j'aurais vraiment la série k&n voyez il
voyait sa meuf il voyait sa mort fait
qu'un autre appel de magasins et or il
est juste très bon exemple de benjamin
c'était à l'époque c'était deux énormes
stars vraiment et flavie selon le dr cb
je
ne sais pas c'est pas non c'est en
comparaison avec aujourd'hui la vie chez
gilles verdez pas tous en quelque chose
et donc peut-être peut-être un jour j'y
crois pas mais pas d'aussi là-dessus